how's it going bro my name
is why can't I move what is this what I
move forward and it goes sideways wait
come on what are you doing ah game do
something about this game game game game
game game game game game game game game
game game what the hell you scare me
little girl I can't even move I swear
I'm not doing anything chop KN Chop knes
Chop I can't even stab that [__]
it keeps going backwards ah die [__]
die come here come here I can't read
that [__] I'm going to die and I have
to replay everything then this is a
problem [__] that what the
hell come on all right see you in a
couple of minutes all right we're
back [__] I can finally move it now oh
you're stuck I feel bad for you stop
need your face just because you're a
Kimbo doesn't mean you're badass all
right so uh Welcome Back To Cry of Fear
and a bunch of raping babies and stuff
hey kitchen
hello what did the kitchen do hey Serene
that I needed that one all right can we
go in here no no senorita lovely couch
love the couch absolutely gorgeous let's
go in here hello business room lovely Mr
sh all the pens looks like Serene what
is
this a Glock magazine that means we're
going to get a Glock soon I think at
least the door won't budge will this
budge I unlock the
lock I thought
like
oh oh what the hell there's the
Glock better take it with
me all right what don't drop you your
drugs buddy come on you need your drugs
you know better than
that all right so I got a hall key and a
Glock [__] [__] better
recognize all right so now when I have
the hall key I guess oh no can we do a
whe
please
what all
[Music]
right yes I Kim [__]
[__] [__] what you
say
[__] shut your [__]
face
uh hold doors I guess is this a hold
door let's try yes I did it I'm a genius
oh no back off babies of Hell holy [__]
what are
you seriously you're not Victoria Secret
models that's for sure but you are
babies all right since this is the
fourth floor I guess we go
up oh
no oh no do not enter well what kitty
cats or babies whatever all right let's
read this now as I need to kill kitties
kitties really I stuck the elevator in
the hall so only the Personnel can
access by secret code I guess no kitty
will find that out so they will just
have to take the stairs my secret not
three all right what's the secret code
then what is the secret
code the one budge what should I do I
have to take the
freaking I mean die [__] babies hate
you I hate you all right uh so we go in
here perhaps then let's kill this
pervert a God damn it elevator there's a
keypad
well I don't know the
number
lead no I guess we have to find the
number like a b all right fine ow stop
be careful with the stairs remember what
your mama said don't run in stairs I
unlocked the
lock wait didn't I come from here no I
didn't it won't all right let's go in
here I don't trust this
hello have I been in
here I don't like this not one
bit what's the point of this Coca-Cola
everywhere what's the point of this I
don't all right fine we don't have to go
there no we don't it's okay anyway all
right I don't know what to do okay okay
of course I know my secret note
one yeah I've definitely been
here
right I don't I'm really confused I'm
sorry my secret
note I'm I I have no sense of direction
it's not my fault yes I definitely been
here
[__] I feel so lost
the hallways are confusing
me so we're here
now stupid computer
die okay so maybe if we go down instead
I guess and stop wasting our ammo too
that would be
fantastic where are we
I'm stop crying no one can
okay I care a little
but
fine I can't even go
there
hello hey lovely let's do a save here
because I don't know what the [__] I'm
doing I honestly have no idea I feel so
lost ah not funny dude not funny dude oh
you recorded I'm message for me sorry
but I don't speak your language even
though I speak
Japanese unlocked a what a hoodie but
why why would they do that that's a Tru
I'll take
that I don't like
this stop oh no oh no oh no let me
reload please let me
reload ow it hurts I have a cell
phone move I'm not going to die from
from a [__] kid penis back up you
sound like a [__] has no that's a
cell phone smash knes bring it [__]
smack smack smack smack smack smack
that's what you guest for being a little
punk all right taking the elevator like
about not sure what the hell I'm doing
but I took the elevator I don't know why
but I took it and we're going up SAS
and
all right lovely lovely
lovely you took the
elevator oh fourth floor [__]
bitching Miss snitching like fre all
right now I need to figure out how to
there we go anyone want to [__] with me
this one was a good one very nice to
kill easy to cut with my knife like like
cutting food all right
awesome all right anyone want to [__]
with me
no don't one but no you're not I can't
see you oh no look at how much ketchup
there's over there that's a lot of waste
of ketchup I don't know why you would do
that hey bucket Sor you blocked the away
here all right so we can't go in there
so I suppose we go in the room of hell
with a lot of ketchup McDonald's you
could call it too no
all right I don't trust this one bit I
know you bro said I should save my
Serene but right now I don't want to I
want don't want to die so let's use the
drugs don't watch kids don't watch
that's all right let's put you there
buddy oh
no oh that more ketchup do this to oh
what the hell what the hell H there's a
key in the bath there's oh how does he
know there's a key in the back
oh that's
disgusting freaking
disgusting I got the basement key you
are pretty I like you oh look drugs from
afraid of moners lovely can I jump in
with you baby you know we you just you
and me can have a little good time you
know lovely absolutely lovely hey drugs
from I told you you just you yeah
nothing a morphine wait this goes to the
basement
lovely all right what why did I go out
here maybe I can clown down from here do
it do
it but how I need like a rope or
something what oh no oh W it's Mom gr's
Mom it's R's mom what should I do I
don't want to [__] with her I mean I
[__] with her before but no no say
Okay Ruben's
mom oh [__] me Ruben's
mom die die die die oh thank God she
died oh oh what the hell girl girl what
happened to you girl I'm going to save
her like a
boss Reuben's mom is not to be messed
with holy
[__] can I climb there now Roman's m
I need a rope fine oh lovely I found the
Rope lovely let's
go uh so
uh you have placed a rope let's go
climbing like a boss what oh all right
so we are here anyone want to tango is
that Glock ammo sweet I need that give
me that
[__] dual whe like a mom mom reload
please reload please reload please
reload do something do
something okay just do what you train
Ruben's mom I hate those charge
[__] ow you're technically ah I
don't like you no no no no no missing
I'm trying to dodge but she's a [__]
[__] smack that all on the
floor I hate her I sincere why did why
didn't I reload where's the ammo I keep
picking up ammo but it never
works all right turn off this we need to
go downtown no we already been in
here all right so we need to go through
basement let's go to the basement Bros I
don't I don't know what about you oh
no oh come on rumors mom [__] you [__]
that all on the floor [__] that give me
some more back up I hate you stop
screaming it's not going to change the
I'm going to chop you anyway yes I did
yes I did you mad bro she's mad like
what is
this what the they weren't here before
Oh put those there
Reuben
Ruben robben's mom
perhaps I already read this yeah I then
all right let's go to the basement oh no
senorita everywhere can't call the
elevator ah damn it what the hell should
I do then I should go to the oh wait
it's locked well the hell this is a
problem all right let's check the other
apartment I hate rum's Mom I hate her
all
right oh come on [__] stop already
I'm not going to die from rin's mom cuz
you're a
[__] m m my I scream louder than you
how about that how about that look at
this [__] I survived with not any health
at all let's usess drugs well needed
drugs Bros oh yeah oh yeah what the hell
is she doing in the bathtub bathroom
that's what it's called H she was what
the hell Rob B I hate you I hate you I
hate you I hate you stop it [__] how the
hell did she punch
anyway pun punch punch like a bot just
die [__] such a wher always complain
about you never going to go anywhere in
life you just complain about things
which floor is this second floor I guess
we can't go any further down I guess so
let's go to the
second I
suppose I don't
know I just
help I can't [__]
you stop screaming it's not going to
change anything I keep telling you
you're just going to die and you're just
going to be ugly all your life that's
what you oh come
on enough it's
enough slap that I slap your puppy I
slap your boob I slap all of them slapy
slapy slapy Slappy how about that you're
mad bro all right let's go in
here all right anyone else want to tango
I already been in here haven't I oh
that's
fantastic wait I go in here it's the
same
room oh there we go all
right you me
good oh this is the
office oh I get it all right let's go in
here come on
Bros we can do this for
Satan oh my God back off back off don't
break doors you're not the Hulk I keep
telling you [__] you [__] you [__] you I
oh God look at how little health I have
please let there be a tape recorder here
somewhere oh God damn
it all right let's go in here but I'm
actually going to end it here cuz I
recorded for a while anyway like and
favorite if you enjoyed subscribe to
become a bro today and I'll see you in
next
episode wow that's not a voice crack
does it look like I need a hospital huh
you need a the hospital you know a
[__] shut up pill do you know what
that is no I never heard of it well you
should buy one cuz all right I'm
finishing this that oh no this is all